so I'd make a point like this and shake
would start laughing uproariously there
you go that's just what I said you order
you know so far you have big slavery's
good domestic slavery girl pauses not
good right I would watch the kind of
intellectual thuggery and that what I
don't know if it is if he's a
sophisticated man who's putting on an
act or if he actually is what he
presents himself to be which would of
course be far worse god
all right glad to be back with our next
guest never sure people ever no feel
amused by the Danziger immensely
uncommon of those for all in comfortable
he is a film out right now it's just
going gangbusters a book of the same
name Hillary's America you already know
who he is you can run a google search
and find him
dinesh d'souza thanks for being here sir
it's great to be on the show yeah well
we're glad to have you and full
disclosure people listening the National
have worked on side projects before so
people don't only have the nest Sean
wise he's really busy and he's above the
show so let's let's just not drag him
through it but your film and the book is
is doing really well obviously he had
kind of Obama's America before was the
goal deliberately to try and affect the
election or just to educate people well
the goal is to educate people in an
election year so I would say this
there's some of both the Obama filmed I
did four years ago was just about one
man it was just about the secret history
of Obama because so little was known
about him right but Obama was an
isolated guy in some ways he's been
detached from the Democratic his own
party for eight years a Hillary is the
leader of a gang and it is this
progressive gang it's the Democratic
gang so I didn't make a movie just on
Hillary I don't think she was quite as
interesting as Obama to be honest I
decided to make a movie on the Hillary
gang how'd it get started what kind of
rackets did it pull what happened when
it got busted how to go on to new things
how to cover up its tracks
so it's actually good it's a little bit
of a Godfather movie I have to say right
well okay this thing about you make an
airtight case and people should
definitely watch it but that brings us
to when you debated shank of the Young
Turks I watched this I thought okay I'm
going to have to see this having been on
YouTube and seeing politican and what
they do and I remember okay let me lay
their foundation people haven't seen it
we've talked about this right away they
debate I'll let Dinesh describe it I
thought well this is a different animal
from what the Nash is used to because
people are usually respectful he's
debated people like Christopher Hitchens
I'm not sure Sam Harris or Dawkins but
they repeat debate because they have
mutual respect and it is and politically
I've debated Jesse Jackson I've debated
the guys on the far left I debated Bill
Ayers at
Dartmouth actually we did a couple of
debates one in Michigan I believe so
I've debated not only the Liberals but
the far left so in that sense I'm
accustomed but generally my approach has
been to maintain good relations with
these guys to have a debate that's
feisty but cordial and that has some
respect for intellectual integrity in
other words the debate in which you
won't have somebody who ignores facts
but pretends the things that are true
are not true
and so with Cheng this was a quite a
surreal experience well you know it's
absolutely true he's gone after me for a
long time and then provided no recourse
so we did a parody of it and we've done
parodies kind of even on this show with
it
um I remembered the first thing he put
up he goes you're on audience but you
lost right afterwards he puts up a
Twitter poll and that flipped not long
after once people cuz he had those
initial people liking and down voting
things before they've watched it because
obviously I mean I have a following that
is many times the size of his so I could
easily overwhelm him in any of those
sorts of polls but I was thinking really
just more of the actual debate itself
where you know he'd say things like you
know you say that blacks were better off
under slavery and I say no I don't say
that but what I say is what Muhammad Ali
said you know Ali of course when he came
back from the rumble in the jungle made
the famous remark someone asked him hey
champ what do you think Africa and he
goes thank God my granddaddy got on that
boat but but behind the the sort of
pungent remark Ali was making a serious
point which is that look his great great
great grandfather was worse off but he
Muhammad Ali is better off for living in
America he wouldn't be the world
champion if he had been born in probably
in some other place like Afghanistan so
he's making an obvious point that the
descendants of slavery are lucky enough
to be living in the inland the orbit of
Western freedom so I'd make a point like
this and shake would start laughing
uproarious there you go that's just what
I said you order you know so far you
have big flavors good domestic flavor
it's gone God is not good right I would
watch the kind of intellectual thuggery
and that what I don't know if it is if
he's a sophisticated man who's putting
on an act or if he actually is what he
presents himself to be which would of
course be far worse
Oh God talk about Sue's was very cordial
but it cuts like a knife even worse
oh I mean in the funny thing is you
would bring up stuff that you've already
this is what I've noticed and and I
since respectfully because like you said
you've been with people who are
intellectual heavyweights and I think
you would probably agree win some lose
some you know it goes back and forth
you've had better nights and worse
nights but I've always known you to
maintain good relationships as you've
said um in this case the technique is
different and I want to get into because
you've sort of bridged more traditional
media with new media better than a lot
of people you debate and I think a lot
of people you've debated they're arguing
to try and convince the audience of
their argument people like jank and this
is sort of generational this new
generation of far leftists they use the
audience to try intimidate their
opposition did you notice that stark
contrasts
yeah well Cheng had a kind of a robot
crew that was in the audience and and I
think these were real people but they
might have been robots I'm really not
sure but in any event every time check
them to say something including the most
pedestrian statements like he would
mention George Bush this audience would
then mechanically jump up and down and
start shouting and applauding so almost
like Schenk was controlling them through
a kind of device of some sort it was
unbelievably frightening because these
are young people who are in a formative
stage of life and you think there would
be some intellectual openness some
curiosity that their idealism would have
some search quality to it but no these
appear to be just sort of you know
either paid robots or just mechanized
robots and so you got you got a sense of
what you know B's when when you think of
the maps movements of the 20th century
people cheering for Castro or cheering
for Stalin this sort of thing this
masked phenomenon I got a little glimpse
of it in politican that that day okay
couple quick questions did you and Chang
shake hands off-camera was he friendly
did you make nice or no I was certainly
cordial with him but I think what what
upset me wasn't so much as personal
incivility it wasn't that it was just
more that there was a certain kind of
intellectual unwillingness to I he'd say
something like you know well as you know
Dinesh all the the Dixiecrats from the
Democratic Party then became Republicans
and I would say well I'm familiar with
the case of Strom Thurmond but can you
name a second case
now obviously you couldn't but he would
say something like there you go again
using your good old debating tactics now
of course were in a debate so you think
debating tactics would kind of me if
anywhere that they'd be legitimate it
would be there but unwillingness to even
you know I just got the sense that I was
debating a wall was he nice to you
afterward was he nice Earp like he was
incredibly malicious impersonal oh yeah
he was he was he was cordial but in he
wasn't friendly and by the way you know
just by way of comparison if I look at
the the whole the whole range of the
atheists for example Hitchens and I were
act were genuinely friends I mean we
would cut a pizza after the debate now
the other guys have debated like Daniel
Dennett you know more pompous and so on
and and so then it was the kind of guy
who kind of felt like outside the debate
he should be cordial but not friendly
and Schenk was was that way he was
withdrawn I didn't say much you know he
shook my hand and so on but it was the
intellectual incivility within the
debate that I thought was particularly
appalling what did look like as it as it
went on you you looked increasingly
uncomfortable because you were going
like it was just any time you would make
a factual statement it got very personal
of course you want to present the prison
of course that's what's his whole thing
and he kept going back to it or nobody's
user Boo Boo's know everything was
remarkably personal if you go you know I
don't mind it being forceful in other
words I would come back and say things
like jank okay look I did exceed the
campaign finance law but you know
justice isn't a matter of did you do it
but it's also a matter of the penalty
hit the crime you know other guys who
did the same thing get the same penalty
so I say I maintain that no no person in
American history has ever been locked up
for doing what I did so a normal person
now on the other side would go wow if
we're claiming that this is progressive
justice that's the problem I need to
find at least some other cases where
other guys got the same penalty
otherwise Dinesh has in fact been
railroaded I never got the sense with
shank that even after the debate he
would make such an inquiry this is a
kind of a guy I mean he almost defines
closed-mindedness in a way that I've not
encountered before and so I was a little
bit it's almost like I felt like an
apologist I wanted to take out my my
equipment and begin to study his insides
because I haven't quite encountered a
[ __ ] before so he wants to he wanted to
go dr. Durant sweeping off the
Velociraptor claws only take a lot of
digging to get to the center of change
so I ask you that because is it true
there are no cases that what would they
say our case is similar to yours or is
there nothing because I did look into it
specifically comparable to yours and I
didn't find anything but that doesn't
mean some of theirs and we know this
because we search for them I mean I have
a legal team that looked for them
because because when you go before a
judge you have to be prepared the
government looked really hard because
they wanted to tell the judge look there
of all these cases where these guys have
gotten but in fact all the cases that
they came up with involve corruption in
other words someone is trying to buy an
appointment or someone is trying to get
a favor through a lawmaker in my case I
didn't even the candidate didn't even
know so there was no corruption involved
or even alleged and and that's what
makes this case particularly interesting
I think it will it's it's done it's
gonna go down in campaign finance
history as a kind of a blip a very
interesting case that people will look
out and go hmm what was that all about
right well people you would have to say
either he's the dumbest criminal in
history who received no benefit
whatsoever or it's just something that's
happened all the time and like you said
they've railroaded him and I think
you've just touched on something I've
talked about so the Second Amendment you
know the help famous Heller case the
argument that loses that's presented is
equally important or the opposition
argument if there were a case like
you're saying it would be in their best
interest to say well here you go here's
a directly comparable case open-and-shut
the fact that they weren't able to was
very telling and this is one thing to
you know we've gotten into this with
Facebook by filing a legal motion you
know you and I both know that what
happens legally in a court that is
legally observable it's very different
from social media drama and you've
you've been in both realms you've been
in the academic realm you've been in the
legal realm and then this new social
media realm which you see with people
like jank the the good side is anyone
can have a voice the bad part of that is
that you have a lot of hacks who can
still develop these huge followings just
through through dirt slinging so does
that concern you the way it's shifting
bridging that gap do you think that's
that's kind of just a
a small trend a small blip or do you
think it could be dangerous well I think
that you're quite right Steven that it
could be a real benefit to democracy
that we've got this kind of open channel
and that the kind of arguments that were
previously confined to the oxford
debating society or PBS are now
accessible to people and people can not
only listen they can participate and I
try to what I try to do is is is bridge
the gap between academia and I'm sort of
popular discourse by speaking in a very
conversational way and I do this in the
movie and in the book so for example in
Hillary's America I make this flame it's
pretty startling I say in 1860 the year
of the Civil War no Republicans owned a
slave I say all the slaves in the United
States in the whole country were owned
by Democrats now this is a very
arresting factual claim there are
there's a very easy way to refute it hey
Dinesh here is a list of 10 Republicans
who owned slaves right I would have to
retract the statement but no one has
been able to do that so this is actually
the way that I think public discourse
should happen it should happen by
asserting and counter asserting claims
by marshaling evidence by making it
accessible to people again I'm not
saying that there's no one in the
progressive side who does that because I
think there probably are interestingly
with this movie and book the left has
not put anyone of any caliber up against
us who's been able to seriously
challenge let alone refute a single
claim in the book or the movie that's a
very important point I think they attack
you more in style kind of like you're
saying you bridge the gap and they're
gonna he's a former intellectual who's
become pedestrian but like you've said
it's making this accessible to people
and if anyone has read your books
frankly um my parents made me read
letters to young Christian and being the
young comedian smartass that I wasn't
like this is kind of dry it's very
intellectually written and something
news to you you you do both of those
things you know and you get railroaded
regardless yeah I mean early in my
career I wrote books that were where
scholar leader was supported by
footnotes now I do that but I also try
very hard to make those books my
assumption in writing now is I assume my
reader knows nothing about the subject
but it's also really intelligent
hilary's America of course it's
available
available on DVD digital as well as
paperback and hardcover all of the above
I don't know if when we'll be coming to
beta don't jump the gun so the DVD of
the movie comes out in October it's not
available yet still in theaters and
we're gonna do an expanded release in
September if you'll let me Hillary's
America the movie.com that's the website
that'll tell you where it's laying near
you absol ittle bit of timing there
where it's both released in theaters and
the DVD before the election I see where
I see where he's noodle in it I do
highly recommend it you have definitely
regardless of where people line up
politically we've talked about this most
conservative content is crap
particularly as far as documentaries
they've been really bad they've been
embarrassingly bad there are a few
standouts but it definitely seems even
if you look at your hiring practices and
the way these films are shot that you've
made it a point to step up in quality
was that your mission from the outset or
is it just something that happened
organically well no I I you know I knew
nothing about making movies four years
ago when I undertook 2016 but I did know
that Christian and conservative movies
tend to be sort of subpar and that
people feel a sense of duty I've got to
go to support the movie now I don't want
people to go to support my movie I want
people to go to be entertained and to
learn a bunch of stuff and to come up
moved and inspired and fired up and so I
wanted to make that type of a movie now
2016 there is that type of a movie but
it's also a simpler movie it's the kind
of movie that you've got a shot on a
handheld a very nice handheld camera but
now that we're doing recreations of
history and recreations of politics we
do them at a very sophisticated level so
for example the confinement center
Prison scenes in this movie there are
people who thought I actually shot them
in prison I couldn't because actually my
judge issued an order that I can't film
my confinement I can't film my teaching
of English immigrants and I can't film
my psychiatric counseling which I'm sure
you Steven would have loved to see the
re-education of dinesh d'souza I would
also want to get the name of your doctor
it could probably help me out it was an
effort that failed and my rehabilitation
plane incomplete well it's one thing to
have obviously to seek help on your own
it's another to have a psychiatric
evaluation and rehabilitate
mandated and then the end result isn't
the opinion they want maybe and they go
wow listen the guys guys still
conservative this is a scary thing about
guys like Schenk is that you know with
generally I would feel that with a good
willed guy on the other side like I have
no desire to lock up Michael Moore or
ruin him financially or subject him to
psychiatric I would never think that way
but these guys think that way now some
of them do there's a sort of
authoritarian streak whether they go
well yeah really glad he got that man
wish we could have kept him you know
under the gun for longer and so this is
the totalitarian streak that you see in
the left and it's uh it characterizes
Hillary and it characterizes a fair
number of her goons well I believe too
that obviously a form of open ideas is
best for the conservative or libertarian
argument that's always what I've
maintained and so have you seen with
good example unedited the Dena shank
debate I would I would recommend you go
review it of course gota to to go see
Hillary's America but this isn't that
was very compelling to me have you
noticed since that is as open and
unedited as could possibly be in influx
of new fans from that because I just go
alright I haven't seen this before well
I noticed two things one is that I
noticed that an influx of new fans a lot
of younger people which who wouldn't
normally have probably come across my
work the other thing is I went on The
Young Turks channel and I began to look
at the feedback on Schenk's site now
well the feedback on my site is 99%
positive on Chang's site it was running
about 50/50 and a lot of people were
like check I thought you were a
reasonable guy but to see you go on like
an intellectual moon at this debate I
was a little bit embarrassed for you and
embarrassed for myself for for being
your fan and so I was I was kind of
interested to see this kind of stuff on
Schenk's own site and I'm sure a chanc
was you know thinking I mean I don't
know what Chang thinks but but I thought
it was significant that even on The
Young Turks I you probably have some
young people who who are more
intellectually open-minded than there
than their hosts well I used to get that
a lot because as you know been young
YouTube for years now was the only one
in there it was just an empty desert and
as a Christian and of course the Young
Turks when they were a little smaller
would go after me and they were I hate
you then they go you know what I've kind
of flipped on this even if they're an
atheist you know even if they would
completely disagree with frig's
imple your debate with Hitchens they've
grown up a little bit and they've
recognized you know what I thought
Schenk was this anti-corporate not just
[ __ ] I don't want a doggie pile on him
but a lot of leftists who have presented
themselves as these anti-establishment
anti-authoritarian z' who've ironically
become the man and you're definitely
seeing an exodus not massive but it's
it's noticeable and does that give you
hope and kind of this area of a very
cracked conservative movement with with
Trump and never Trump you will on the
Left you've seen these sites like Gawker
and Daily Beast and media and so on and
you've got these guys and many of them
are you know two years at a college and
and they don't know anything so they'll
tell they'll say things to me like des
no ship you ever heard of this Nixon
Southern Strategy
you know and I think yeah I heard about
I've written extensively about these
things I wrote a 2,000 page book called
the end of racism I'm very familiar with
all these things but they they they have
this sort of you know idiot way of
lecturing me about things that I'm that
a you know sort of everything that they
know on the topic was my starting point
20 years ago so I don't quite know what
to make of this I try to engage them in
dialogue by saying things like well you
know who actually won the deep south in
68 it really wasn't Nixon it was the
Democrats the segregationist Democrat
Wallace and that Nixon won the upper
south so the least racist south as the
south became less racist and became more
Republican so I you know I I'd love to
have real debates about these things
like the big switch and so on but the
quality of the debate I mean it throws
me back to when I was 20 and I looked up
to people like Irving Kristol Bill
Buckley Solzhenitsyn Hayek Milton
Friedman and I realized that those guys
were writing in small magazines and in
different forums and the world is
different now but it is pathetic to see
the lowering of the intellectual
lowering that has happened between then
and now right I think you're you're
smart to say I assume that the audience
knows nothing but is not an idiot we've
had that we've run into that a lot with
Second Amendment issues where we talk we
assume right sort of like a tree you
okay there's a branch semi-automatic
then you get two assault weapons clips
versus magazines and then you realize
you're still at the trunk they don't
know what semi-automatic means so you go
okay let's back this
they're not idiots they just don't know
anything about this given subject and so
I do appreciate you you bridging that
gap because there aren't a lot of people
doing it they're either in academia or
they're hacks like us who are dancing
along to to techno bumps Dinesh we're
gonna go to a web extended after this
the website right before we go Hillary's
America the movie comm and then the book
is available in Costco and Barnes &
Noble everywhere else you can get books
a lot of people my age that's what they
do they believe in the switch right well
you know before it was in the Civil
Rights Act and then they all switched
then although the Democrats became not
racist and Republicans became racist I
want you to take the ball and go with
that because I was it's your realm of
expertise one thing I never hear them
say and I've brought this up in the show
but what about FDR then is he claimed by
your people or is he claimed by
Republicans since he wasn't a racist how
does that work and they go homina homina
homina homina well not all of them maybe
explain it for our audience was bought
into that that lie well all the three
progressive heroes of the twentieth
century and I'm thinking here of Woodrow
Wilson FDR and Johnson are very bad on
the race issue all of them now generally
the left conceives on Wilson they can't
deny that he expanded expanded
segregation the federal government say
no he screamed the pro Ku Klux Klan
movie in the White House they don't
stress us but they know that led to a
big Ku Klux Klan revival now FDR they've
been pretty clever in in camouflaging
FDR's dirty deeds in FDR's dirty deeds
or to this is the deal he made with us
with the Democratic racists to get the
New Deal through number one they said to
him FDR you have to agree to block all
anti-lynching laws block all
anti-lynching laws and FDR agreed and
the second thing was they said blacks
mainly work in domestic service and
agricultural labor we want you to
exclude those from most New Deal
programs and FDR agreed again so this is
the way in which FDR was in bed with
some of the worst I ask a quick question
for devil's advocates sake would they
say well he blocked lynching laws
because there were already laws on the
book or do they just gloss over it
entirely no there were laws on the books
but the Republicans were proposing anti
lynching legislation that would override
if you will these state laws on Lynn
there will be a federal prohibition sure
on state lynching laws FDR had no states
rights issue with any of this of course
but what it was was that it was a
Prudential pact that he made with the
racists in the Democratic Party
so that's FDR Lyndon Johnson cynical
wanted to keep blacks by his own words
on the plantation and he figured out
that that the Civil Rights Act was the
way to go now interestingly more
Republicans proportionally voted for
that civil rights act in 64 and the
Voting Rights Act in 65 and the fair
housing bill in 68 then Democrats did
this is not well known and this is
allowed Democrats to say well Lyndon
Johnson and then they hijacked the whole
civil rights movement as if they did it
but in fact the opposition to the civil
rights movement came from the Democratic
Party the infamous sheriff Bull Connor
Democrat Arkansas governor Orval Faubus
who stood in the schoolhouse door
blocked black kids from getting into
school Democrat and so the if the
Democrats had been the only party in
America no Republicans none of those
laws would have passed yeah when also
they would have been much more effective
at blocking if they'd have hired a good
guard back then but they were all black
so it was a problem so we're moving down
I know the Strom Thurmond case right
people always bring that up that's there
boom trump card outside of him could
they argue a swap took place whether it
be directly you know political
affiliation or or even culturally sort
of in the political divide lines in the
south now there was the swap that they
talked about did not take place but
there was a different swap that did take
place that has nothing to do with race
so for example the swap that did not
take place if you look at the Dixiecrats
you make a list of them's a pretty big
list Strom Thurmond is the only one who
moved over to the Republican Party so
this is a case hinging on one guy the
rest of the Dixiecrats they were happy
to be Democrats they went right back in
the Democratic Party they were lionized
by the Democrats the day they died a
good example this is Robert Byrd form a
member of the Ku Klux Klan I mean Obama
went to his funeral Bill Clinton was
there Clinton by the way made a very
interesting statement he goes you can't
blame good old Robert Byrd for being in
the Klan because and now I open quotes
you had to be in the Klan to advance in
the
kradic party and have a very interesting
admission well it's also important to
note context and so this rubber bird
didn't dabble in the clan he didn't do
it as a necessity he was high up there
he practically had clan dental and a
company car let's not kid ourselves well
and the Grand Wizard I believe is the
one who said to him you know young Bob
you got a lot of talent you need to go
into politics this is from bird's own
account of how he first went into
politics so when he said the N word on
national television was at 2001 or 2004
repeatedly in the racist context you got
a lot of light n words you know you have
white n words out there and he said it
twice like he didn't even realize you
don't say this anymore so it's not like
he left it in the past in the 70s this
was still sleeping through in the 2000s
well you got a guy like David Duke and
you know and he's the Republican Party
repudiates him denounces him doesn't
want anything to do with him and yet
people say oh he's a Republican Byrd was
a member in full standing of the
Democratic Party never repudiated
Hillary calls him when he dies for
mentor so this is the difference the
Democratic Party loves these guys and
makes them feel at home with them
whereas the Republican Party has always
tried to hit the eject button gosh you
got it Wow Robert Byrd big influence but
I've got hot sauce black voters supports
pandering it's like the aunt who shows
up at the barbecues like I got a funny
story like no no stop it tours coming
back to the switch the the it is true
that the blacks who used to be
Republicans the party of Lincoln did
move over to the Democratic Party but
they didn't do it because of race they
did it in the 30s because of the
promises and actual economic benefits of
the New Deal so you may only say that
blacks were bribed into it they they
knew that they were leaving the party of
Lincoln and emancipation and the 13th
14th and 15th amendment and they were
joining the party of segregation and the
Ku Klux Klan now white Republican is
white Democrats did move over to the
Republican Party but that was between
the 70s and the 90s basically in the
Reagan era again this has nothing to do
with bigotry Reagan was appealing to
patriotism free markets traditional
values Christianity
and that those are the issues that cause
the non racist South to swivel over to
the Republican Party which makes it even
more interesting if it occurred before
what they need to be the timeline for
their swap because it would only
reiterate the idea that racists found
solace in the Democratic Party right so
the big switch is really a big scam I
mean it's it's the last [ __ ] defense of
the of the Democrats see the first thing
is they kind of have to admit their
involvement in slavery so they go Dinesh
why are we talking about the antebellum
crimes of the Democratic Party and I go
well and I'm also talking about the
postbellum climbs of crimes of the
Democratic Party who invented
segregation who passed all the
segregation laws in the south who
started the Ku Klux Klan who revived the
Ku Klux Klan who used the Klan as the
domestic terrorist arm of a political
party for 30 years who was in bed with
fascism in the 30s who interned the
japanese-americans in world war ii so
then they go because they now realize
this is getting uncomfortably close to
the present and they then go well big
switch big switch so the big switches is
like the lawyer who said initially you
know my client was not on the scene then
yes he was he wasn't the scene but you
know he didn't he wasn't the one who
fired the fatal shot and then finally
well yeah he did but it was in
self-defense so we have this kind of
migrating leftist attempt to exonerate
the Democratic Party which in fact has
been not only implicated it's been the
perpetrator of the vilest thieves of
American history gosh that is a that is
a great put it in a nutshell so we'll
make bring it to the final point then
because I'll say well let's let's get
past what happened in the the 20s 30s
40s 50 67 lat
today racism is owned by the Republican
Party I maintain that listen no party
owns racism I don't say the Democratic
Party today is a party of racism I don't
believe that nor do I believe that the
Republican Party is a party of racism
but they argue the opposite racism only
exists in a Republican Party today well
you know neither party is involved in
racism in the old sense and so for
example a good metaphor this would be
the client the client today is
essentially defunct there's no real
effective organization called the Klan I
mean the Klan used to have 2 to 5
million members they could march tens of
thousands of people down Fifth Avenue in
the 20s burning crosses and shouting
racist slogans that Klan does not exist
but I would argue I was actually reading
the book by the historian Kenneth stampp
and it's on the old slave plantation is
called a peculiar institution and he
describes the five features of the slave
plantation I think this is really
interesting because all the five
features he mentions are present today
but they're present on the urban
plantations that the Democrats are
running in the inner cities and so
Kenneth stampp says number one on the
typical old slave plantation you have
ramshackle dwellings houses but they're
in disarray second you have the family
structure is all broken down a lot of
illegitimate see whose kids are whose
you don't really know that's the nature
of slavery third a lot of violence
that's necessary to hold up keep the
place together because slavery is based
on coercion you have to force people you
have to whip them beat them etc forth
everybody has a minimum provision you
get food you get health care but nobody
gets ahead nobody gets a good education
no ladders of opportunity nihilism
hopelessness and despair so you take all
these elements and ask house is really
different today an inner-city Oakland or
Detroit or Chicago I think the main
difference is that in the old days the
Democrats who ran those slave
plantations to wanted to steal people's
labor they wanted labor they wanted
labor for free right now what they want
is votes they want votes and they don't
care about these people and that's why
they remain in misery and the Democrats
are perfectly happy to keep them there
as long as they keep voting 80 to 90
percent for the party that's running the
plantation well that's a good point may
even look at Milwaukee I said well
Milwaukee's been run entirely by leftist
Democrats for over half a century and
someone said uh-uh and they pointed out
there was a socialist there an actual
socialist the Socialist Party all right
I'll give you that one about
60-something years and and these are the
results I mean I don't think anyone
could argue with the results as far as
leftist cities versus certainly more I
guess conservative right-wing limited
government petri dishes like Texas or
Dallas but they argue culturally that
you know racism is more alive on the
right and I you know I just don't see it
I see it across all spectrums and I try
and be even-handed out that this for a
moment even though because it's an
important issue take something like
people said well who's the party of
states rights today well the Republican
Party but that proves nothing because
there's nothing wrong with defending
states rights as long as the principle
is not being used to uphold
his states rights as an honorable
principle that's right in the
Constitution it was used for a bad cause
in 1860 and that's put the idea in
somewhat of a bad odor but it doesn't
mean some guy who wants states rights
because he wants the ones local
governments to pass laws on abortion or
on gun rights is there for some kind of
a closet
you know Confederate right well the
problem is there was the whole
confederate uproar a while ago where
people were defending Confederacy you
know the Confederacy under states rights
I'm gonna know because that does
supersede natural rights of people being
free I think it's a good thing that they
lost you don't have to agree but that
kind of hurts you know an intellectual
argument that you or I would make and
that was a little bit of a setback yeah
part of what we do here is we show the
importance of Lincoln to the Republican
tradition and to establishing the
principles of modern American
conservatism the Democratic Party was
the party of the segregation of south
and to be honest the Democrats if you
will you have to ask well how did the
South's become so monolithically racists
in the early part of the 20th century
and the reason was that the Democrats
had political strategies to make it that
way they found ways to capitalize on
white supremacy in order to suppress the
black vote in order to weaken the
Republican Party right and the theme
isn't all that different from today
right with divide and conquer and black
lives matter they are seeking to create
more racial divide I've talked about
this I know you have you know you have
nephews and nieces I believe who are
about my age our generation of black
Americans my generation of black
Americans will be worse off than the two
previous if you look at corn gains you
look at the way a lot of these these
kids are being raised because a lot of
people my age are raising children at
this point right it is it is scary and
and it's very different from even the
80s or 90s where I was raised as a kid
where we had black friends II didn't
even think about it now there is so much
more racial divide you have white
content you have white entertainment you
have black entertainment and if one
crosses that line if you just see it on
Twitter they are excoriated by the black
community there have been some steps
taken back and I argue that's by design
you see it by big leftists who they have
a vested interest in us being divided
and and stoking the fires of a racial
war and well this is why we've seen no
race
and a good deal of regress under Obama I
might have expected or hoped for the
something different with Hillary I think
she's a different bird than Obama is by
the way and even though the two of them
have common threads and they both were
tutored by Alinsky or by Olinsky i'ts I
think the difference is that Obama at
the end of the day is an ideologue and
now his ideology to my way of thinking
is pathetic it's twisted it's deformed
it reflects Obama's own miserable
childhood but nevertheless he believes
it for man he thinks he's making America
and the world better and Hillary on the
other hand I think the Clintons are not
that way they're more like Bonnie and
Clyde because our two grifters they're
two ripoff artists they label on right
out of Mark Twain they were running
rackets in the Arkansas days stealing 50
cents here making a buck over there when
they got to the White House they're
renting the Lincoln bathroom they're
lifting pictures off the walls and
taking curios out of the cabinets I mean
they're selling pardons to big-time
racketeers and felons so this is how
they operate them this is what I think
we're up for not so much an ideological
America but a gangsta rised America and
that's what the Clintons represent think
it's an important contrast to make
Hillary's America the movie.com I've got
that correct right yes you do and the
same title and the book of the same
title and of course it'll be out on DVD
before the election everyone please go
out there and and watch it listen if
even if you're listening you're an
atheist leftist we have a lot of those
people hear what the other side has to
say Dinesh thank you sir
my pleasure okay if you like this video
subscribe by hitting subscribe or watch
one of the videos in a box playing next
to us Dinesh doesn't do this a whole lot
so he can just stay there and look
pretty hit one of the boxes there